bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoint dans
filch l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec le sommaire
de cette émission la ministre de la
Famille a été accueilli par des
manifestants àentes les syndicats FO et
CGT estiment que Dominique bertinoti ne
prête pas attention à leur revendication
concernant la
CAF Airbus group EPSA poissi dévoile
plus en détail les suppressions de
postes li à leurs plans sociaux les
chiffres dans un instant et puis le
dossier de la semaine sera consacré à
une jeune pâtissière Caroline a passé
mardi l'épreuve de qualification pour la
finale du championnat de France du
dessert nous l'avons suivi et enfin nous
parlerons microcrédit à l'occasion de la
Semaine du microcrédit qui débute le 3
février dans toute la France et bien
entendu dans les ivelines nous n
recevons Isabelle treger bonsoirir vous
êtes la responsable de laad dans le
département notamment on vous retrouve
dans un instant juste après les infos
économiques de la
semaine ce sont des salariés en colère
qui ont accueilli la ministre chargée de
la Famille à la cave de manth Dominique
bertinoti venait inaugurer ce matin des
locaux rénovés les employés
syndicalistes FO et CGT avaient déjà
tenté de faire entendre leurs
revendications lors de ces deux
précédentes venues sans succès il dénonc
la vente de locaux de la cave dans le
département une baisse de 15 % du budget
de fonctionnement des conditions de
travail dégradées ou encore un
plafonnement des salaires ils ont
brièvement été reçus par un membre de
son cabinet la ministre elle de son côté
répond à l'inverse que des améliorations
sont survenues ces derniers mois on
écoute les deux partis et nous ce qu'on
souhaite surtout dire à Madame
Bertinotti mais qui ne recevra pas
aujourd'hui c'est tout simplement qu'on
veut bien un accueil rénové on veut bien
des des locaux tout neufs mais on veut
surtout du personnel derrière les
bureaux c'est une initiative aussi qu'on
a pris qui s jamais passé la C des
divines de réunir aujourd'hui de
Saint-Quentin de mandes de Saint-Germain
au des collègues qui viennent
aujourd'hui dire à la ministre ça suffit
on peut plus travailler comme ça voilà
on peut avoir toujours plus d'effectifs
on peut mettre toujours plus de moyens
c'est la solution je dirait la plus
facile aujourd'hui nous avons cette
exigence quand même nous sommes dans un
cadre budgétaire cont
de travailler aussi bien voire même
mieux et le fait d'avoir de mettre du
personnel là où c'est le plus nécessaire
c'est ça que les syndicats doivent
défendre et plaider on n sait plus
concernant les plans sociaux pour Airbus
Group et PSA Airbus group le nouveau nom
de ADS avait annoncé qu'il supprimerait
5800 postes au total en Europe lundi
lors d'un comité européen la société a
précisé les sites touchés les ivelines
n'ont pas été épargné 411 postes seront
supprimés sur le principal site de
cassidian à hencour on note également
309 suppressions d'emploi sur le site
des Mureaux pour rappel le Groupe
réorganise ses activités celles
d'Astrium et cassidian seront notamment
regroupées le groupe PSA de son côté a
annoncé aujourd'hui la suppression d'une
équipe de production dans son usine de
poissie 684 postes sont concernés en
cause un recul des ventes la direction a
indiqué qu'il il aurait pas de
suppression de postees mais des
reclassements la CGT ne croit pas
vraiment en cette promesse nous suivrons
donc cette actualité l'usine emploie
actuellement 6700
personnes les chiffres du chômage ne
sont pas bons pour le mois de décembre
3303200 demandeurs d'emploi en France
soit 0,3 % de plus qu'en novembre et une
hausse de 5,7 % sur 1 an les chiffres
locaux ne sont pas encore connus pour le
mois de décembre mais d'après les
chiffres de de novembre on compte dans
les Yvelines 58800 chômeurs une hausse
de 8 % sur 1 an un chiffre supérieur à
la moyenne française mais le taux de
chômage étant assez faible à la base les
fluctuations se ressentent
davantage un nouvel outil pour le
covoiturage arrive à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline la start-up Wazup propose une
application mobile pour mettre en
relation des salariés du territoire des
images de Jonathan villman effectuer son
trajet domicile travail seul dans sa
voiture reste une réalité pour beaucoup
de salariés peu écologique et peu
économique la startup WAZ up cherche à
faire bouger les choses en développant
le covoiturage il propose une
application mobile pour mettre en
relation les personnes intéressées par
ce mode de transport ce jeudi il
présentaient leur outil aux salariés du
Technocentre Renault l'application
permet de trouver des coitureurs selon
le trajet souhaité et calculer les frais
réels même lorsque l'on ne finit pas à
une heure fixe chaque jour un système
plus maniable et plus souple que les
sites existants si vous finissez pas
toujours à la même heure le principe
c'est que on crée des petits équipages
de covoiturage où en fait un passager va
avoir plusieurs conducteurs possibles et
via l'application et en quelques
secondes le conducteur dès qu'il sait
qu'il va partir 30 à 40 minutes avant va
pouvoir alerter ses passagers et le
passager va pouvoir se greffer sur le
conducteur qui part à la bonne horaire
la société travaille avec des
entreprises partenaires elle payent un
forfait pour offrir ce service à leurs
salariés et prof de reporting élaboré
par Wazup pour leur communication
l'application est d'ors et déjà proposée
à plusieurs entreprises du territoire
Renault n'est plus seul Renault avec les
acteurs locaux la CaSki mais aussi la
snekma d'autres entreprises il buig on
se lance dans cette démarche pour
essayer d'avoir ce qu'on appelle une
masse critique de de covoitureurs
potentiel et qui vont pouvoir partager
et créer et créer une communité de
covoiture potentielle pour les salariés
de Renault rencontrés sur place ce
volume élargi de covvoitureurs est
peut-être la clé du succès donc on pe se
reconnaître entre nous voir les
entreprises qui sont vraiment autour du
Technocentre ça peut vraiment être utile
Renault envisage d'intégrer cette
application à sa tablette Airlink et
donc au véhicules de la marque mais il
faudra encore quelques mois pour tester
son
efficacité et c'est aujourd'hui qui a
lieu l'inauguration du Vélodrome une
inauguration pardon en grande pompe
puisque la ministre des Sports sera
présente un tournoi de vitesse aura
également lieu entre les équipes de
France et d'Angleterre mais au-delà de
l'aspect sportif le vélodrome représente
un énorme projet économique pour
Saint-Quentin en Yveline nous avons en
direct de la piste notre journaliste
sportif Anton r bonsoir bonsoir claire
alors pour le 7 sport vous suivez ce
projet depuis longtemps finalement sur
quel modèle économique
repose-t-il tique principale du
vélodrome de saanttineline est
évidemment son financement le Centre
national du cyclisme français est porté
par un partenariat public privé financé
à 75 % par des fonds publics l'État le
conseil régional le Conseil Général et
évidemment la communauté d'agglomération
de 50 ans Rivlin tout cela pour un total
de 74 millions d'euros alors évidemment
la question que tout le monde se pose
est-ce que le vélodrome sera-t-il
rentable sur la durée pour cela
vélopolis mise sur les loyers versés par
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme pour
l'utilisation de ses bureaux mais aussi
sur les nombreux événements et les
manifestations sportives autre que le
cyclisme et des manifestations
culturelles à l'image du concert Dima
qui sera donné ce soir après les
compétitions sur la piste des recettes
qui seront en partie reversées à la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 an en
Ylin très bien merci beaucoup Anthony
pour ces explications passer une très
bonne soirée on retrouve le détail de
cette inauguration dans notre JT de
demain et nous développerons ce ce côté
financement ce côté modèle économique du
Vélodrome dans le filcho de la semaine
prochaine on passe maintenant à
l'entretien le sujet de cet entretien
c'est le microcrédit alors pourquoi on
parler maintenant et bien parce que on
fêtera la semaine du microcrédit la
semaine prochaine du 3 au 7 février
c'est un événement organisé chaque année
par lad l'Association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique nous recevons
justement sur ce plateau la responsable
ilinoise Isabelle treger bonsoir bonsoir
alors ce n'est pas la première fois
qu'on évoque le sujet sur ce plateau
mais pour pour ceux qui ne connaîtrai
pas encore ce qu'est le microcrédit en
quoi cela consiste-t-il alors le
microcrédit c'est un microcrédit
professionnel donc c'est un un prêt qui
est accordé à des demandeurs d'emploi
des personnes qui souhaitent créer leur
entreprise leur petite entreprise micro
parce qu'il est c'est un petit prêt il
est associé aussi avec un prêt d'honneur
à tau zéro et puis une subvention du
conseil régional pour ceux qui créent le
leur boîte alors cette semaine de du
micro océdit donc a lieu chaque année
c'est l'occasion également de
communiquer sur votre association et ses
actions vous avez d'ailleurs lancé une
vidéo
promotionnelle ça s'appelle ouvre ta
boîte il me semble donc on voit à
l'image une petite vidéo donc du coup
amusante quelqu'un qui essaie d'ouvrir
une boîte on comprend facilement le
parallèle avec l'ouverture d'une
entreprise vous expliquez également sur
votre site que vous utilisez la création
d'entreprise comme util de lutte contre
le chômage et contre la crise alors
finalement on comprend très bien le
concept mais est-ce que tout le monde a
les épaules pour cela alors pour créer
sa boîte effectivement c'est pas si
simple et puis la vidéo le montre bien
puisque on voit à quel point on peut
être maladroit bon créer sa boîte c'est
c'est une affaire qui est importante on
peut créer sa boîte tout seul maintenant
avec l'auto-entrepreneur ça semble
facile et en fait il est très important
d'être
accompagné pour monter sa boîte pour
bien mesurer dans quoi on s'engage et
puis aussi pour être épaulé au quotidien
nous a dit on finance donc les personnes
qui veulent créer leur boîes sur des
petits financements pour toutes les
personnes qui n'ont pas accès au crédit
bancaire donc si elles ont accès au
crédit bancaire tant mieux elles vont
pouvoir bénéficier d'un de soutien
financier d'une banque si c'est pas le
cas laad est là et surtout on propose un
accompagnement à ces personnes pour les
aider à se lancer à démarrer leur
entreprise et ce ce prêt peut justement
débloquer ces fameux prêt bancaires qui
qui manquent à la base alors justement
avant de d'aller un peu plus loin dans
dans ce microcrédit on va écouter des
témoignages de personnes d'entrepreneurs
qui ont été suivis par votre association
on commence avec Marie irirma tota elle
a ouvert en 2009 une boulangerie à
coanière vous pouvez peut-être expliquer
un peu la situation elle avait connu
quelques difficultés oui elle avait
connu des difficultés elle avait été
obligée de fermer sa sa boulangerie elle
avait du mal à retrouver un emploi et
puis il y a eu une opportunité elle
pouvait récupérer le local elle pouvait
récupérer le matériel par contre elle
avait plus du tout accès au crédit
bancaire et elle a frappé la porte de la
maison d'entreprise d'abord de la
casquie puis de laad et ça permis en
fait de complètement dénouer la
situation c'est c'est Paul emploi
finalement qu' avait qu' avait conseillé
ce ce cursus je vous propose d'écouter
justement son son ressenti c'était pas
la banque qui était derrière vu la
liquidation personne ne vous faisait
confiance à part la dit parce que je
n'avais même pas cru parce que les
banques même pour ouvrir les comptes
c'était même pas possible
donc avec les 10000 € là on a pu faire
ouvrir les portes et redémarrer ça fait
un an passé qu'on est là mais ça va
c'était un crédit de 10 1000 € mais au
moment où j'en avais besoin pour
démarrer c'était comme si on m'accordait
100000 € quoi c'était 10000 € mais ça a
servi à ouvrir presque toutes les portes
parce que avant de reprendre le on le
bailleur vous demande peut-être 3 ou
4000 € avant de démarrer l'autre demande
peut-être 7000 € par ici mais il y avait
il y en avait pas il faut pas il faut
satisfaire tout le monde ah voilà un bel
exemple elle avait donc du coup du coup
les clients qui étaient là qui
l'attendaient mais il lui manquait des
finances pour rebondir elle emploie donc
du coup aujourd'hui deux personnes un
boulanger également une vendeuse et en
tout cas elle nous indiqué que ça marche
très bien pour elle exactement elle a
créé deux emplois et le sien donc trois
emplois trois emplois en tout donc une
belle histoire autre exemple un
entrepreneur également qui n'avait pas
la confiance des banques Mathieu Pradal
il dirig une une entreprise de service à
domicile donc de bricolage et de
jardinage donc lui également a connu des
difficultés il a dû fermer son
entreprise avant de repartir sur de
bonnes bases avec lad on écoute
également son témoignage il fallait
investir beaucoup pour progresser et à
l'époque j'avais pas les fonds et donc
j' préféré arrêter plutôt que de
m'écrouler et pour mieux reprendre en
septembre dernier aujourd'hui ça marche
très bien laad m'a permis en septembre
de
reprendre ma société en en acceptant les
les fonds que j'avais besoin parce que
les banques ne prêtaient pas avec fait
prêt mais avec des garanties trop
élevées et trop importantes pour moi et
donc laad m'a permis de d'avoir les
fonds et de pouvoir investir j'ai pu
avoir des nouveau devis et contrat que
j'aurais pas pu avoir sans avoir le
matériel donc du coup plus de clients
donc plus de chiffres le reboursement se
fait en mensualité donc qui sont revu
par rapport à ce que je gagne et que du
coup c'est des petites mensualités
et ça permet de pas avoir trop de charge
en plus de ce qu'on a déjà en tant
queation compte al Mathieu Pradal parle
notamment du du remboursement vous
l'indiquez tout à l'heure des taux à des
taux zéro pardon alors le le prêt qui
complète le microcrédit effectivement
est à taux zéro mais le microcrédit a un
taux d'intérêt qui est à
7,78 donc en gros on a à peu près 2/3 du
montant c'est avec un taux d'intérêt
puis un/ers sans taux d'intérêt et en
plus pour la création d'entreprise il y
a une prime du conseil régional donc une
subvention ça c'est important ça fait un
effet fait de levier pour les personnes
qui veulent se lancer avec un petit prêt
elles peuvent acheter un petit peu de
stock ou le stock de démarrage le
matériel de démarrage voir un petit
véhicule utilitaire d'occasion pour
pouvoir se se lancer et tout à l'heure
vous l'avez vu avec Madame tota ça va pe
aller jusqu'à 10000 € maximum mais notre
prêt moyen il est plutôt aux alentours
de 3000 € donc avec 3000 € on peut déjà
commencer on peut se lancer et nous
justement on est là pour expliquer ce
que l'on peut faire et aider les
créateurs et l'objectif de la semaine du
microcrédit c'est ça c'est d'aller au
plus près de notre public
de montrer que c'est possible de faire
témoigner effectivement des des des
micro-entrepreneurs qui se sont lancés
et de leur montrer aussi qu'on est là
pour les soutenir alors ce qu'il faut
noter tout de même les deux
entrepreneurs donc dont on a entendu le
témoignage ont lancé eux-mêmes leur
société ont connu des difficultés puis
on réussi à rebondir avec laad on peut
aussi faire appel à vous pour se lancer
dès la première oui et en fait c'est
principalement notre public ce sont
surtout des gens qui se lancent pour la
première fois qui qui prennent contact
avec nous qui sont par exemple des
demandeurs d'emploi depuis longtemps qui
recherchent un emploi qui n'en trouvent
pas et qui ont une idée avec lesquelles
on va travailler on va travailler avec
aussi nos partenaires de la création
pour les aider à monter leur projet et
puis on sera là ensuite pour les pour
les financer et pour continuer derrière
le le soutien et donc le cas de Madame
tota ou de Monsieur Pradal qu'on a vu
c'est pas le cas le plus fréquent mais
il faut savoir aussi qu'on est là pour
ceux qui ont connu les difficultés qui
veulent recommencer rebondir alors vous
parlez donc du coup de de demande
d'emploi qui par exemple bah créent
eux-mêmes finalement leur postees est-ce
que également avec la conjoncture
actuelle vous avez plus de jeunes qui
n'arrivent pas à se lancer sur le marché
du travail dès dès la sortie d' l'école
du coup qui se disent pourquoi pas oui
alors on a des jeunes effectivement on a
donc un dispositif particulier pour les
jeunes avec un prêt qui a un taux
d'intérêt qui est plus intéressant pour
les jeunes jusqu'à 32 ans on a aussi un
dispositif de formation alors pour les
habitants de la casquie c'est un enterre
mais avec un train direct jusqu'à la
défense ça reste possible avec une
formation qui dure 8 semaines et qui
aide les jeunes à passer d'une idée à un
projet vraiment structuré donc ça c'est
un un atout particulier pour les jeunes
pour retrouver confiance en eux c'est
gratement c'est gratuit c'est absolument
c'est gratuit et on a aussi une action
particulière auprès des femmes des
femmes qui sont isolées qui bon
dépendent souvent de enfin en tout cas
dans les quartiers qui peuvent avoir
uniquement des revenus sociaux et ça va
leur permettre en créant leur petite
entreprise leur petite activité
ça va leur permettre d'avoir des revenus
complémentaires et progressivement de
prendre leur autonomie le taux de
réussite on a une petite idée alors taux
de réussite donc parlons déjà de taux de
réussite des entreprises au bout de 2
ans 70 % de nos micro-entrepreneurs sont
toujours en activité dans leur
entreprise au bout de 3 ans alors un
certain nombre on fermé ce que l'on
mesure nous c'est le taux d'insertion
c'est-à-dire que cette expérience de la
création d'entreprise elle peut se
transformé là l'entreprise peut durer
dans donc 58 % des cas on est peut-être
parfois aussi obligé igé de la fermer
mais on peut rebondir vers un emploi
salarié et finalement nous ça reste une
expérience professionnelle exprience
importante et qui permet d'avoir 84 %
des personnes qui au bout de 3 ans sont
réinsérés soit par leur entreprise soit
par un emploi alors on va conclure avec
les dates donc les dates de la semaine
prochaine à venir les différents
événements donc lundi 3 février vous avz
vous organiseer une réunion
d'information donc au Promopole des
merisers à trrappe à partir de 14h30 ça
mercredi 5 février de 9h à 17h un
accueil individuel cette fois des
premiers conseils pour se lancer dans
son entreprise toujours au Promopole à
trrappe et enfin vendredi 7 vous
concluez de 9h30 à 16h vous serez
présent au Forum de l'insertion organisé
par la cask on pourra vous y retrouver
du coup exement et bien je vous remercie
en tout cas d'avoir été présente avec
nous ce soir et puis on espère du coup
que que les candidats seront nombreux la
semaine prochaine son les bienvenu pour
ces événements merci beaucoup on passe
tout de suite au dossier de la
semaine
voici près de 3 mois que Caroline se
prépare au championnat de France du
dessert cet élève de l'école hôtelier de
Guill enc tenté mardi de se qualifier
pour la finale nous l'avons suivi de ses
préparatif jusqu'à l'épreuve des un
dossier pardon réalisé avec Jonathan
villman Caroline fruchot est étudiante
au lycée hôtelier de guillancour après
un BTS en restauration elle a décidé de
se spécialiser en pâtisserie mais
aujourd'hui elle ne suit pas un simple
cours elle s'entraîne pour les
championnats de France du dessert moi ça
me tenait à cœur de réaliser un concours
cette année quand on commence pour voir
un peu ce qu'on
vaut se mesurer aux autres VO le travail
qui a accompli qui a
accomplir et alors du coup vous pensez à
avir toutes vos chances
j'espère son professeur Jean-François
Gautier la coach depuis plus de 3 mois
et il croit aux chances de réussite de
son élève à tout c'est son grand sérieux
sa capacité de se concentrer et de
rester dans ce qu'elle fait dans son
sujet son dossier a été sélectionné pour
les championnats de France du dessert le
28 janvier elle passe le concours î de
France en jeu une place pour la finale
nationale notre jeune pâtissière a
décidé de travailler des poires et de
les décliner de multiples façons une
poire bien mur c'est juste extra c'est
super bon
ça me fait penser à mon père en fait
c'est un fruit qu'il adore et du coup je
pense c'est pas mal lu faire un petit
clin depuis 5 semaines Caroline a
accéléré sa préparation elle s'entraîne
maintenant 6 heur par jour car au
concours elle devra connaître sa recette
par cœur elle aura 3 heur pour tout
préparer de la confection au dressage
d'assiette mais ce n'est pas le temps
qui lui fait peur c'est une histoire de
température dans mon
dessert qu' a beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui sont fraîches pour être enfin
qui sont froides même et ça doit pas
être des froids trop négatifs bonne
température texture visuelle goût
technicité et hygiène les critères à
remplir sont
nombreux Caroline a découvert la
pâtisserie sur le tard c'est lors d'un
séjour en Allemagne qu'elle a trouvé sa
voie professionnelle j'étais dans un
palace 5 étoiles et j'ai vu une fille
une pâtissère on m'avait proposé de
faire un stage dans C là et la
pâtissière cétait juste génial et m'a
vraiment transmis son savoir son toute
sa passion du métier et du coup voilà je
me suis dit pourquoi pas faire moi aussi
pendant qu'elle poursuit sa recette son
professeur l'observe et note sur ce
tableau les points à améliorés j'ai vu
des choses qui sont pas encore parfaites
mais rien n'est jamais parfait mais qui
sont à finalisé on va dire là vous voyez
j'ai noté par exemple les âmes en la
toréfaction ne me convient pas donc on
va retravailler on va repenser faire
attention au temps il lui reste encore
un peu de temps pour corriger ses
imperfections le jour du concours est
arrivé il est 8h30 le top départ vient
d'être donné Caroline s'active entourée
de ces six concurrents son professeur
attend en retrait il ne souhaite pas la
déconcentrer c'est très important donc
c'est aussi beaucoup de stress et voilà
on attendant de démarrer une fois qu'on
a démarré je pense que après elle va se
libérer je l'espère Carol se concentrer
sur sa recette pendant qu'un jury de
travail observe ses faits et gestes il
juge la technicité le savoir-faire
l'hygiène et attention il faut que la
réalisation concorde avec les photos
envoyées dans le dossier de sélection le
jury est composé de chef pâtissiè réputé
la réussite à ce concours est donc une
bonne carte de visite ça permet d'ouvrir
des portes ça permet de rencontrer du
monde effectivement he là les les jeunes
les jeunes apprentis qui sont là
aujourd'hui bah ça va être nos nos
Comines nos employés de demain quoi donc
c'est intéressant de les rencontrer
aussi la concurrence est rude les
candidats rivalisent d'imagination ici
des planète là cette belle architecture
exotique les concurrents ont beaucoup
travaillé en amont mais malheureusement
certains n'arriveront pas à respecter
les délais ce candidat doit livrer ses
desserts en laissant de côté quelques
ingrédients il a manqué de temps pour
dresser ses
assiettes à l'assiettei il y a pas de
marqu rglement on peut pas amener de SAU
à c'est que à l'assiette
dans la salle de dégustation les
candidats s'enchaînent ils ont tous
démarré à 7 minutes d'intervalle pour
laisser le temps au juges de goûter
chaque plat un à
un allez prier dans
minute jusqu'au bout Caroline vérifie
les derniers détails tout doit être
parfait pour présenter ses desserts au
jury de
dégustation
moi aussi je veux
bien c'est
horrible bonjour messieur donc
aujourd'hui moi je vous propose un
délice de poire donc pour la dégustation
je vous conseille de commencer de la
plus petite à la plus grosse comme ça le
goû du chocolat va pas l'emporter sur le
goû de la poire voilàell cation
merci pendant que les chefs dégustent la
jeune pâtissière peut enfin souffler
c'est un peu le stress parce que B même
si je me suis bien entraînée au lycée
ici c'est un labo qu'on connaî pas c'est
une pression qui est complètement
différente et en labo je le faisais en
2h et quart ben ici pour vraiment que ça
soit parfait pour finer à fond et tout
bah j'ai mis 3h au moins une quoi donc
c'est vraiment c'est clairement
différent et mais bon c'est un bon
stress donc bon on ver ver quoi de leur
côté quand non pensé les juges il y
avait une certaine grâce dans sa
présentation CIT très fin sa façon de
travailler ça s'est vu que elle s petite
bille de
poire son petit décor en chocolat très
fin ça se voit que c'est une fille aussi
qui l'a adessé donc c'était très très
fin mais après le plus important c'était
le goût donc là d'autres candidats ont
été aussi très très performants Caroline
et les autres candidats ont laissé place
au professionnels l'après-midi avant de
découvrir le verdict et c'est la
Parisienne Marie matthos pour sa 12
planète exotique qui remporte le Premier
Prix Caroline finit 2e à quelques
miettes d'une place pour la finale
nationale et dans l'agenda on notera de
date une journée d'information sur
l'industrie aéronautique et spaciale les
prévisions de recrutement sont non
nombreux du CAP au diplôme d'ingénieur
alors on parlait pourtant de
licenciement dans le groupe Airbus tout
à l'heure pour en savoir plus
rendez-vous donc à la Cité des métier le
5 février et puis une matinée
d'information sur le métier de boulanger
pâtissier ça colle avec notre dossier
vous avez donc rendez-vous le 6 février
de 10h à 11h30 à la Cité des Métiers
toujours et c'est la fin de ce filcho
merci d'avoir été avec nous je vous
retrouve jeudi prochain pour un prochain
numéro d'ici là très bonne soirée